triumphant scenes like this are playing
out across eastern ukraine
the national colors rising
russia's laid low
this soldier's selfie is from the city
of isiam he says everything's been
destroyed but it'll be restored the city
had been a vital hub for russia's
invaders in hakeev region
no more
a voice can be heard crying glory to
ukraine glory to the heroes glory to the
nation
death to the enemies
elsewhere another soldier says ukrainian
troops have recaptured a border crossing
in total the lightning advance has
already retaken territory equivalent to
more than two times the area of greater
london
the russians forced into a hasty retreat
close to the border with russia this was
once a busy ring road around hakeev city
russian forces in the early days of the
war tried to take it but they were
beaten back
yet they did manage to take the border
crossing point with russia which is
about 20 miles in that direction
ukrainian forces however say that they
have managed to recapture that point
we can still hear noises going on
explosions in the background so this is
still clearly an active area
down the road is evidence of the heavy
toll the whole region has paid over the
past few months
sir he used to live in this block
he fled to another area but returns
every day to feed the birds
ukraine's counter-offensive bringing him
new hope
he shows us how he had to start storing
water after a russian missile strike the
previous day cut off power and
electricity at his new flat
do you think that russia launched those
strikes yesterday in revenge for this
operation that ukraine is doing
australia
it's a conviction that's widely shared
and is strengthening each time russia
strikes
debra haynes sky news in kharkiv